the FIFA roster has gotten a little
smaller professional soccer player Adam
Johnson has been removed from several
soccer games after his child sex
convictions good riddens Johnson a
former England international and
Sunderland midfielder was found guilty
last week for engaging in sexual
activity with a 15 year old schoolgirl
the 28 year old player who presumably
made around 85 thousand dollars a week
was removed by sunderland AFC in
February after pleading guilty to one
count of grooming and one count of
kissing the victim now Johnson faces a
five year sentence Electronic Arts told
GameSpot that Johnson had been removed
from the game but that more time would
be needed to purge his name and data
from all modes Adam Johnson had been
removed from the active rosters of both
Sunderland and England and FIFA 16 we're
looking to remove him from other modes
within the game as soon as possible you
won't be able to find Johnson on
football manager or pro evolution soccer
either according to Digital Spy